I was never showed it was about training
for the sake of training that appealed
to me I've always been a fan of martial
arts rock climbing and parkour but
whereas I've trained those things for
radically I've always stuck to my
strength training and my general fitness
routine lately though I've been
reflecting on this and I've come to some
kind of answer I think that training the
way I do appeal to me because it
develops traits and attributes rather
than skills as such when there isn't
enough time in the day to pursue all of
my interests in activities training
strength speed agility balance and even
focus helps me to improve in all of
those things I call this super
functional training functional training
is training to become more comfortable
and stronger during everyday tasks
sometimes it means training to
supplement your abilities in a
particular sport or athletic event super
functional training then means training
to be able to do more than is required
by everyday life or to train in ways
that will benefit sports that you never
plan to compete in and I think that
everyone should train this way they
shouldn't treat their training just like
rehab to help them feel and move a
little bit better the way they were
supposed to be able to do in the first
place they shouldn't just treat it
mainly just to build a sexy six-pack and
not only for a specific skill or sport I
think we should all train to be the very
best that we can be a trained martial
artist will kick your ass no matter how
strong you are the coordination and
muscle memory required to deliver a
perfect punch is far more important than
the muscle behind it but while that is
true a martial artists will become
better at their craft by building more
strength speed reflexes and mobility
someone who's trained all these
attributes will likewise last a little
bit longer against the trained martial
artist
they look why are the skills necessary
to fight more quickly and if you take
two people with no fight training then
the fitter stronger one will win by
training mobility their kicks and knees
will reach further increasing their
likelihood of landing a hit by training
strength they will have access to
greater reserves of power even the
perfect technique is limited by the size
of the muscles and by training endurance
still lasts longer before their strike
start to lose that power of speed this
is why I think that Conor McGregor's
trading with Egypt portal the movement
guru is far more than just a publicity
stunt actually makes a lot of sense and
it's why Brazilian jiu-jitsu benefits
from kettlebell
Bell training to open up and strengthen
the shoulders and to increase stability
likewise being fast and explosive will
make you better at parkour and sports
greater muscle endurance and grip
strength will help with rock climbing
being focused and having greater
emotional control helps the athlete or
the orator not to croak under pressure a
working memory with more capacity will
allow us put bullets as visualized
positions of every player on the pitch
having a stronger core will make you
better at pretty much everything of
course all these traits can help outside
of athletic pursuits too whether you're
gardening moving furniture or
armwrestling a friend all these things
benefit from being strong fast agile and
focus and they helped me to be ready for
the unknown further things you can't
predict to prepare for that's the reason
I love training it helps to improve
performance across the board so that
you're able to rise to any challenge and
perform in any capacity you don't have
to narrow your options by choosing just
one thing to excel at it drastically
increases the number of options
available to you at any moment but only
if you train the right way and that's
why I like this kind of training in
particular and it's why I believe the
cross modal training is superior to
doggedly focusing on just one aspect of
performance because if all you're doing
is the three big lifts in an attempt to
get stronger that won't translate the
greater performance in parkour or
martial arts it won't help you to run
faster or swim a mile you may be
extremely strong but you're only used to
exerting that strength in one plane of
movement your body composition may be
slowing you down your range of motion
might be missing in some areas and
entire aspects of your strength will
likely be overlooked how is your
straight arm strength your shoulder
mobility your rotational strength
bodybuilding create strength with lower
peak output is compared to powerlifting
but greater endurance thanks to those
longer rep ranges the crafts are super
heroic physique and it targets muscles
missed by powerlifting but it also does
little to Train intramuscular
coordination or maximum muscle fiber
recruitment and it still misses out
whole crucial muscle groups like the
obliques
calisthenics will build your straight
arm strength for sure it will create
amazing relative strength that helped
you to perform incredible gravity
defying movements the handstands trains
and men's four prior section of body
control
but calisthenics alone can provide no
substitute for the heavy squat or
deadlift a plyometric jump squat is just
not the same as loading a huge amount of
weight onto your shoulders and then
bracing against it as you move into a
deep squat for multiple reps
that builds huge peak strength
intramuscular coordination and denser
bones even nor can calisthenics provide
the same kind of hypertrophy and muscle
size as bodybuilding due to the maximum
weight available though one type of
training hits every attribute needed for
complete performance but each brings
something new and important to the table
kettlebells will open up your shoulders
build your work capacity and provide a
ballistic strength not to be confused
with plyometric or explosive strength
high-intensity interval training and
metabolic conditioning will increase
your lactate threshold and your
mitochondrial count low intensity
steady-state cardio meanwhile will build
will and determination while growing
your left ventricle for lower resting
heart rate and superior physical health
yoga Pilates and gymnastic strength
training will increase your free range
of motion and doing the stiffness that
comes from years of sitting and
repeating the same few movement over and
over again the old-time strongman
favorite of overcoming isometrics will
develop crazy grip strength and enhanced
muscle fiber recruitment passive quasi
isometrics creates amazing muscle
control making sure you aren't weak at
any point in the movement and teaching
you to move more efficiently by
contracting only the muscles you truly
need during a given Reitman
don't even be limited to things we
typically think of as training wrote
it's from science from history and from
forums online think outside the box and
realize that everything can be trained
meditation helps to stay focused and on
task mental toughness will ensure that
you keep going and stay strong in your
lowest moments ambidexterity will help
to perform equally well with all four
limits now if you take someone who's
trained it in all these different
disciplines and then get them to throw a
punch for the first time they'll be able
to call upon impressive max strength and
power lifting powerful torque through
the obliques thanks to calisthenics and
a powerful posterior chain from cattle
swings
they'll be focused quick to learn and
able to loosen their entire body before
contracting the moment of impact when
sparring they'll last longer in the ring
when throwing kicks will benefit from
superior balance and mobility for those
same skills will also help them to climb
to flow over obstacles to win games of
chess and to excel at any sport I'm not
saying don't specialize if you want to
compete at the highest levels in
powerlifting or long-distance running go
for it and choosing a skill be it dance
martial arts or memorizing decks of
cards and honing it to perfection is a
noble pursuit indeed but if you're not
training for anything in particular then
train to be the most well-rounded
version of yourself
don't just get obsessed with
on one specific list don't just train
your amps don't just fix your bad
posture don't train to be better at what
you already are trained for what you
wants to become so why not have a go at
climbing that rope you've noticed in the
corner of the gym why not get outside
your comfort zone and try a heavy
deadlift or alternatively a pursued a
planche push-ups why not train your
brain just like you train your body and
whoever you are don't be jealous and
tribal by sticking viciously to your one
kind of training claiming superiority
recognize the unique value that all
these systems have to offer and it's
just the icing on the cake that training
this way also keeps things exciting
action-packed and varied training should
be the furthest thing from boring if you
don't like working out because it's
boring then you're doing something wrong
so thanks Sam for watching this one guys
I hope you found it interesting and
useful let me know what you think in the
comments down below do you combine
multiple different training methods do
you see value in it or would you rather
stick to one thing and be a master of
one rather than the jack-of-all-trades
if you want to learn more about this
kind of training then you can check out
my ebook and training program super
functional training in the link in the
description down below alternatively
just subscribe to this channel I've got
loads more cool stuff on the way thanks
a ton for watching this one guys and
I'll see you next time
bye for now
there will knock us to the ground at the
ground they will knock us to the ground